[Music]
if you're like us your impatiently
waiting for Riverdale's third season to
come out on Netflix and with the way
things left off in season 2 there's no
way of knowing how things will unfold if
there's one theory we can't shake it's
the idea that chick is in 6 feet under
like how claims him to be watch until
the end to find out which actor
confirmed our suspicions first time with
the things don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up now let's get to the
bottom of things and find out if chicks
still alive or gone for good if you tell
anyone it'll be bad for Betty and Alice
what there's more to check than meets
the eye
Betty Cooper grew up with the notion
that her family consisted of four people
as the years went by however she soon
found out that her mother Alice had
given her firstborn son up for adoption
knowing that reuniting with her son
would bring her great joy that he
located her long-lost brother chick and
brought him home before long however
Betty realized that there was more to
chick than he'd previously let on after
being forced to cover up her murder on
his behalf the Cooper family turned a
skeptical eye to their newfound family
member this led them to uncover the
truth that chick was nothing more than a
phony
even though Betty turned chick over to
the black hood many of us believed him
to be alive after all someone as
manipulative as chick could easily
convince how to put down the pitchfork
on more than one occasion how had an
opportunity to confess chicks murder but
has yet to do so is it possible that
chicken hell are working together
towards a common goal or did how keep
chick alive for questioning before
getting thrown in jail while it hasn't
been confirmed we can only speculate
that someone as intelligent as chick
would manage to escape someone as
simple-minded as Hal Cooper he had the
chance to escape Betty Cooper might have
the tendency to go dark but that doesn't
make her evil after all she did give
chick the chance to escape the black
hoods grasp after delivering him to the
murderer I'd say you have about a 70%
chance of making it
where he cuts you down really you should
start running it's one thing to pose as
a family's long-lost son but another
thing entirely to murder someone in
their home make them cover it up and
then threatened to blackmail them all in
all we'd say that chick had it coming
but that doesn't mean that he's gone for
good
now that it's been revealed that how is
the black hood we're left to wonder if
he actually finished the job in the end
how isn't in tip-top shape so could he
really outrun chick since how never
confess to murdering him it's very
possible that chick escaped and is now
keeping a low profile at the end of the
day chick is a smart guy so laying low
while plotting his revenge against the
Cooper's is definitely a possibility
let's face it Hal is far from being a
criminal mastermind so it wouldn't be a
surprise to find out that he left some
loose ends behind Betty gave chick
plenty of time to escape his faith so is
it that unreasonable for us to believe
that he ran like his life depended on it
because well it did know death scene the
last time we saw chick he was running
for his life across a cemetery so why is
it so hard to believe that he's six feet
under if there's one thing movies have
taught us it's that without a death
scene there's no surefire way of knowing
that a character bit the bullet we
wouldn't call Betty a murderer but her
actions on the night of chicks
disappearance were highly questionable
after all handing someone over to a
murderer sort of makes you an accomplice
after holding chick hostage at gunpoint
Betty brings him to the Riverdale
cemetery where she receives a call from
the black hood convinced that Betty will
let him go chick stands in disbelief
when she reveals that the black hood
will cut him down if he doesn't start
running immediately this gives way to a
suspenseful scene one word chick seems
to be outrunning his predator if it was
indeed chicks time to perish we're
confident that River Del's producers
would have showcased his death however
the scene was cut before the famous
murderer could catch his prey the open
ending leaves a lot to the imagination
which is why we're guided to believe
that chick is still kicking it somewhere
in Riverdale
no body no confirmation if there's one
thing we've noticed
that hiding his victims bodies are at
least one of the black hoods worries in
fact he'd rather leave them out in the
open for the entire town to see this way
he gets to instill fear in the Riverdale
community we know the hoods obsessed
with cleansing the town of sinners and
hypocrites right
knowing this Betty spent a lot of time
at the Riverdale morgue where she
impatiently waited for chicks body to be
brought in after receiving a call from
dr. curdle betty decides to identify the
body of a 20-something year old man but
alas it isn't chicks body that she came
across unable to confirm whether the
imposter is dead or alive that he
decides to let it go and resume her
everyday lifestyle so if making his
death count known is a great priority to
the black hood
why hasn't chick's body been found not
only was chicks murder omitted from the
show but his body never turned up in
Riverdale as many of you know how
soon-to-be-ex-wife
isn't the easiest person to get dirt on
so why would how get rid of the only
person who could put Alice Cooper behind
bars Alice and Betty are guilty of
covering up a murder
but without chick the drug dealers body
will never be found
since house family has turned their back
on him he might be thinking of telling
the police about their crime or at least
making Alice believe that he'll stoop
that low
is how smart enough to think that far
ahead or is she too embarrassed by the
fact that chick managed to outrun him
regardless of his motives there's no
crime if you can't find the body
actress machen amick accidentally
spilled the beans actors are supposed to
keep their lips seals when it comes to
spoilers but when it comes to actress
and machen amick who plays the role of
Alice Cooper it seems as though keeping
secrets isn't a priority during an event
from mental health awareness amick spoke
about chicks character and how she
couldn't wait to see what he had in
store for us in season three so if you
had any doubt in your mind that chick
was still alive here's the proof
although it's a big slip up on her end
Amick played it off as though it were
nothing special so one thing to keep in
mind is that the actress might be trying
to stir the pot by spilling lies to the
media whether chick returns to Riverdale
or not it's safe to say that we deserve
some answers and hopefully the third
season and will fill us in on what
happened to check and where his body is
hidden for now we have no choice but to
wait for our speculations to become
facts do you think that chick is still
alive if so let us know what your
theories are and that's it for our video
we hope you enjoyed the show see you
next time on the things
[Music]